People BET on you were Bert to die
people would go bird
huh of course how interesting that bird
has made his own sound in the world how
many people have made their own sound
sound that's a really good point that
type of squeal I think you can only make
that sound if you enjoy yourself that
much he's so pleased with himself my
whooop bracelet will get things from him
some it'll just be like oh Bert's not
doing good really yeah I wonder what a
parlay would he like yeah I just feel
like God floated red growing
head his head keeps growing which is
crazy his head is swelling oh in the
middle of the night I got a sodium high
score the other night I was like how
what is that that MRI on Bert must just
come back all [__] like a the first
part is appetizers you're like how is
this if you bet the under on BT I think
you could you could see some money this
you know yeah you could see some money
by
2028 the flood plane on his [__]
kidneys it's a lot it is a lot